[Music]
so here we are the last episode in this
series of the deep mind podcast my name
is Hanna Frey I am a mathematician and
someone who is deeply intrigued by
artificial intelligence much like you I
imagine since you made it this far now
we've been toying with the big questions
in this series what is intelligence how
does an algorithm learn and what to do
with the AI future once we get there and
I've been asking the team of scientists
and engineers here at deep mind to give
us their take of where things are at and
where they're going but now for this
final episode we have a chance to catch
up with demis hassabis the co-founder
and CEO of deepmind to hear what he has
to say on these questions and more demos
SRBs grew up in North London in the
1970s by the age of 13 he was ranked
second in the world at chess in his age
group at 16 he worked as a games
designer remember theme park that was
him then he went on to study computer
science and then neuroscience before
setting up deep mind with his two
co-founders Shane Lake and Mustafa
Suleiman his accomplishments are
ferociously intimidating but as an
article in The Times put it Dennis
doesn't even have the good grace to be
socially deficient but if all of that
makes it sound like Dimas is a man with
a plan then you'd be right I had in mind
something like creating a company like
deep mind to research AI from a long
time ago so I was sort of working back
from the end state which is what would I
need what skills would I need what
experiences do I need to even stand a
chance of building something like that
because these different aspects of your
life the chest the neuroscience the
games designed they're not disconnected
I mean they do build to a bigger picture
they do and it's hard to say which way
round it is so I picked those subjects
and those things to study say computer
science at Cambridge and then cognitive
neuroscience at UCL because I wanted
this component of computer science and
neuroscience to come together and
obviously that was what we do at deep
mind but even the game staff that taught
me about creative thinking
also a massive engineering projects and
then of course it's ended up that we've
used games as our main vehicle for
proving out our AI algorithms one other
thing I've learned from games is to use
every scrap of asset that you have luck
in games you always have a limited
resource pool like you know if it's a
chess game it's the chess pieces you
have left on the board and one way to
think about games is maximizing the use
of the of the assets you have left
perhaps that's why I was biased towards
using games but I also felt it was the
logical way to go about building AI what
was your PhD in my PhD was in cognitive
neuroscience and I actually decided to
study how memory and imagination works
in the brain and the reason I chose
cognitive neuroscience is I wanted to
better understand how the brain does
certain cognitive functions so that
perhaps we could be inspired on new
types of algorithms based on how the
brain works and so it's a good idea to
pick functions that we don't know how to
do in AI and I went to study with Elinor
McGuire at UCL and she's one of the
world's leading experts in the
hippocampus which is critical for memory
but I told her that what I really wanted
to look at was imagination which is you
can also think of it as simulating
things in the future in your mind for
obviously useful for planning but also
for creativity and the reason I was
interested in that is of course that's
an incredibly important part of human
intelligence and it's also something I
used a lot in my games design career so
I used a lot of visualization techniques
and imagining how would a player
viscerally like play this game like
theme park and then you try and change
something about it all in your mind
before or in Skechers before you went to
the trouble of programming all and it
felt to me that we were using a similar
type of process to the way when we
lucidly remember things that happened to
us so I thought there may be there would
be a connection with this kind of you
could imagine like a simulation engine
of the mind that was being used both for
imagination and memory and that's what I
wanted to work on during my PhD and we
ended up discovering something quite
important that then in fact the
hippocampus was at the core
both of those two types of function is
critical for memory which we already
know but it's also critical for
imagination and you can't really imagine
vividly without your hippocampus so we
ended up discovering this important
thing and then subsequently that's been
at the heart of a lot of what we've
tried to do in AI is build memory and
imagination abilities into our AI
systems and we're still doing that now
when it comes to bringing those ideas
across and trying to implement them in
AI where do you find that balance
between just directly copying what the
brain is doing and using it for
inspiration so that's a very important
signpost when you're scrabbling around
in the dark of in the unknown of science
any signpost is really valuable and the
brain is the only existence proof we
have in the universe that intelligence
is possible so it always felt to me that
it would be crazy to ignore that as a
source of information of how to build AI
so we use neuroscience for two things
one is inspiration for new ideas about
algorithms or architectures or
representations that the brain uses and
then we can get some inspiration for
that for new types of algorithms the
second way we use neuroscience is what I
call for validation so we may already
have some idea from coming from
engineering or mathematics about how to
build a learning system let's say
reinforcement learning that came from
engineering disciplines and operational
research first but then in the 90s we
discovered that the brain also
implements a form of reinforcement
learning and what that means is is that
from an AI perspective you can be sure
that reinforcement learning could
plausibly be a component part of an AI
system because it's in the brain and we
know the brain is a general intelligence
so that means that's really important if
you're thinking about where to put your
engineering resources and effort you
know that if it doesn't work right now
and things never work first time in
research or engineering it's worthwhile
pushing that harder because you know
eventually this must work because the
proof of concept is the brain having
said that though there are another
school of thought from AI practitioners
and neuroscientists that we need to
slavish ly copy the brain completely
from the bottom up like on a neuronal
level and I
think that's also the wrong approach
what we're after is what I call a
systems neuroscience approach which is
that you're in stood in the algorithms
and the architectures that the brain is
using not necessarily the exact
implementation details because I think
that's likely to be different for in
silico systems like computers compared
to carbon based systems like our minds
there's no reason to think that we would
implement exactly the same
implementation details in a
silicon-based system that's going to
have different strengths and weaknesses
to a carbon-based system like our minds
[Music]
normally tech startups have customers
they have products but this is sort of
more like a start-up research facility
yes how do you get something like that
off the ground it's pretty hard I mean
you're right in that it's a very unusual
company what I try to do is basically
take the best from the startup world the
kind of focus and energy and pace that
you get in the best startups say in
Silicon Valley and I wanted to combine
that with the best form academia which
is you know blue sky thinking incredibly
bright people working on you know
long-term big research questions and
stepping into the unknown all the time
and you know obviously I spend some time
in academia myself and there's very
great aspects about academia but there's
also some things that are frustrating
mostly around the organizational aspects
and the pace of it can sometimes be
slower than you would like it's
difficult to get momentum behind things
in the way you can a startup if it's you
know if things are going well but I when
I was in academia and I had already
obviously started and been involved with
a few startups before going back to do
my PhD so I'd experienced both sides and
I didn't feel like there was any reason
why these should be mutually exclusive
environments although they have
generally been treated as very different
almost opposite environments and there's
a lot of things that do seem opposite
but I felt if if you were kind of smart
about it you could extract the best of
both those worlds and combine them into
some kind of hybrid organization and I
feel that's what the mind is and I don't
think many people have ever done that
and and so that's why it seems quite
strange probably as a
zatia n-- i think we've shown with our
scientific output even if you measure it
by normal measures nature science papers
this kind of thing that normal academic
labs would measure themselves by we've
been very successful and i think you
know we've a bee net also on the other
side of things we've been able to
produce really big breakthroughs that
took a lot of engineering effort as well
like alphago which would have been very
difficult i think to do in academia in a
normal you know small academic lab one
other thing that makes deep mind i guess
a bit unusual is that you publish your
work I mean other companies don't really
do this is there somewhere that you're
kind of giving away your competitive
advantage really yes an interesting
issue actually so we've always published
everything we've done and lots of
companies do want to you know why we're
doing that because a lot of other
companies don't necessarily do that we
feel it's part of the scientific
discourse like that's the right way to
do science we really believe in sort of
peer-reviewed journals so that your work
is scrutinized at the highest level by
your peers which is the bina the gold
standard in science that's why we
publish in the top journals like Nature
and Science
also you do get more exposure for your
ideas like that so some of our top
papers have been cited like more than
5,000 times now in the last two three
years some of the most cited papers in
the world so that's great you know and I
think if a community shares ideas like
that the whole field can advance much
more quickly than if everyone was to
keep their ideas secret but you know
there are some interesting aspects to
that one is the competitive side I mean
I feel there that you just need to carry
on innovating at a faster pace than
anyone else that's the most important
thing not trying to keep hold of the
ideas you've already innovated you
should just be by the time you've you
know you've published it you should be
one or two idea is even further down the
line if you're continuing to work at the
same pace and the same level of
innovation so I think that's really the
biggest sort of protection against
competitors is your pace of innovation
in the early days I mean back in sort of
you know 2009-2010 when AI wasn't the
hot topic that perhaps is today did you
find it difficult to get attention from
from the people master I mean I think I
remember reading that you you decided to
go straight for billionaires rather than
millionaires yeah
to investment yes well that was
incredibly tough so it's really hard to
remember now even for me like ten years
ago you know no one was investing in AI
it was a impossible thing to get money
for actually you know no one would
invest and it's still very difficult
today I think on it at what I would call
a deep technology or science based
startup right and with no clear product
in mind I mean what we were basically
saying is we were going to build this
incredible general purpose technology
that as it got more powerful there
should be a myriad of things you could
just apply it to but you know that
sounds probably pretty far-fetched to a
normal kind of investor it was almost
like well that's what academia is for
isn't it you should be just if you don't
know you know it's blue sky research we
don't know when it's going to work it's
it's pure research then go and do that
for another ten years in academia and
then come and talk to them when it's
working but that would have been too
slow and I could see that within
academia so then that's why I decided
not to go after normal venture
capitalist who certainly in Europe and
in the UK you know they would want to
make 10x return maybe within three to
five years right that's the kind of time
horizon of course that's no good for a
research based company you know you have
barely got going after three years right
so what you need is a profile investor
who is more interested in thousand X
returned but they're willing to wait ten
years maybe even twenty years and that
kind of profile of an investor basically
just does not exist in Europe certainly
did in the back in 2010 really you're
talking about
Silicon Valley self-made billionaires I
guess who both have deep enough pockets
to take that kind of bet and if it
doesn't work it's okay but they're also
personally interested in these types of
topics and have seen incredibly
ambitious things work because usually
that's how they've made their money just
going back to the idea of how everything
sort of slots into place all the
different aspects all the different
pressures that you have slots in space
didn't chess play a role in you getting
your first funding yes it hits so chess
has been key you know core part of my
personality I guess it because I've been
playing it for so long and I think a lot
of my thought processes developed
because of that so planning and thinking
about problem solving all of these
aspects which I think
for any thing you do in your life but it
also turned out to be useful directly
because one of the first investors we
talked to was a chess player themselves
and a pretty strong junior chess player
in the US and when we were doing sort of
our background reading on this we spent
about a year preparing for this meeting
almost and it was important meeting
because we knew that not very many
people would get what we were doing and
this was one of the people we felt that
would so it was important and we
couldn't get a meeting because we had no
contacts in Silicon Valley you know I
didn't know anyone over there in
California nor did Shane and Mustafa you
know and it's sort of how do you break
into that world and so we finally
managed to get asked to a conference
where this billionaire was sponsoring
and then we knew we would meet him at
some kind of after conference party but
the problem is is that there are
hundreds of people all trying to pitch
him their ideas so if you if you're just
another one pitching you're another
crazy idea it's very unlikely you're
gonna get noticed right so I thought
instead of that I'll take this
calculated risk and talk to him about
chess instead but then you have to have
something interesting to say about chess
that maybe haven't thought of so I used
my number one fact on chess that even
surprises grandmasters which is the
thinking about it from a games designer
point of view you know why is chess such
a great game how did it evolve into such
a great game and what is it that makes
it so great and my belief is that it's
actually because of the creative tension
of the bishop a knight the bishop and I
are basically worth the same there three
points each so you can swap them off but
they have completely different powers
and that asymmetry the sort of creative
asymmetry that happens with the bishop
and knights being swapped into various
positions I think is what makes chess a
fascinating game and so I basically
pretty much led that with that line I
don't know how I managed to crowbar that
into a drinks party but I did and it
made him sort of stop and think which is
exactly what I was hoping and then he
invited us back the next day to do a
proper picture on our business idea so
we actually got half an hour with him
rather than one minute over over some
drinks so that actually you know worked
out so you could say chess works on two
levels in the meta level of planning for
that and also actually chesses and
tweaking subjects in itself so actually
getting funding from billionaires is
really
spent the year studying their interests
come up with a genius idea that will
catch their attention in a way you can
do a good picture after that exactly
easy simple very straightforward one
thing that you hear time and time again
in this building and actually throughout
this podcast series is how deep my wants
to use artificial intelligence to solve
everything so here is the chance to ask
what do they actually mean by that do
they want to be the ones addressing
every one of the world's problems once
intelligence is cracked so I you know I
have a list it's a working list of a
dozen to a couple of dozen of scientific
problems that I feel are these kinds of
root node problems and if we could crack
all of those then I feel like that would
transform society for the better and
open up all sorts of areas in you know
medicine and science for us to make
breakthroughs in go and give me the list
some of the lists of things like I think
a key thing we need to crack is cheap
abundant energy that's renewable and
clean and so if there's fusion or just
way better solar panels with way better
batteries with room-temperature
superconductors that would also solve
that problem so you know I think there's
a number of solutions to that some a
material science solution some of
physics solutions and we should have a
go cracking all of those but if you
crack that then that would open up all
sorts of new issues so I'll give you an
example
water access access to clean water is
going to become increasingly more
important as the population in the world
grows right and it's already becoming in
some countries more valuable than oil
because you know there's just so little
fresh clean water around right for a lot
of communities so they specially poor
communities this incredible problem but
we have a solution already its
desalination right 70 percent of the
earth is water but it's saltwater so how
do we deal with that well desalination
technologies exist the problem is they
cost too much energy they're too costly
so some rich countries can do it so I
think Israel gets a lot of their water
like this and some other countries like
that but for the poor countries it's too
expensive so if you solved the renewable
a clean-energy problem then you would
automatically solve the water access
problem almost straight away because
that's actually the issue so where do
you want to be when the water salination
problem is solved where do you fit into
that story I hope that we will have been
integral in coming up with those
solutions by doing something say in
fusion or in material science more
likely where we've come up with using an
alpha zero like system you know the
battery that is 50 percent more
efficient and cost a tenth of the price
of current batteries and lasts you know
ten times longer you know we would come
up with a solar panel photovoltaics
material that is twice as efficient at
converting heat energy into electrical
energy so it will be something like that
would then unlock the possibility of
making desalination within reach of
every community perhaps there has to be
some improvement with the desalination
technology itself as well and maybe we
could be involved in that but you know
we're relatively small company so and
we're going to stay relatively small so
we have to be efficient with the
solutions that we work on this all just
comes at least from my perspective from
rationally logically thinking out what's
the best thing you can do and what's
happened so far looking at civilization
in this I mean maybe you could say as a
slightly strange way of looking at it
but I think it's the correct way to look
at things and I think most people just
don't think about questions in the right
way and maybe that's what I've done in
my whole life is try to ask for the
right questions and I feel like this is
the obvious answer this is deep mind the
podcast an introduction to AI one of the
most fascinating fields in science today
okay I always say to people whatever
your question the answer is AI because
it sort of is in the limit right I mean
that's a little bit flippantly but I
mean in the limit it must be because the
answer so far you know why we're here
while we're talking while using these
Khmer zhing computers and devices is
because of intelligence human
intelligence and I think it's miraculous
and the scientific method another
miraculous thing I think that the
greatest discovery of all is that the
scientific method works you know the
Enlightenment and why should it be I
mean also you must have to question
things like that why should the universe
work like that that the scientific
method works you know it could be a
little bit more random then he'll be
really confusing right if sometimes the
Sun rose and sometimes it didn't
requires to do science then why
sometimes he repeated the experiment
with exactly same conditions something
else something something different
happened but it doesn't this world
doesn't seem to work like that it seems
to be repeatable it seems to be
consistent so therefore knowledge is
possible and incredibly strangely our
brains even though they're evolved
hunter-gathering can somehow deal with
it
which is kind of Iraq Yunus in itself so
how can you not want to a work on those
questions and B why would there be
limits to what that is capable of doing
but the ultimate goal in all of this is
to create artificial general
intelligence exactly what is meant by
that
nothing yeah artoo there's not an agreed
definition of artificial general
intelligence but the way that Shane and
I think about artificial general
intelligence is a system that is capable
of a wide range of tasks and if we think
about human level artificial
intelligence then we're talking about
system that can pretty much do the full
spectrum of cognitive tasks that humans
can at least as good as humans are able
to do that's you know one reasonable
definition of artificial general
intelligence what's the threshold for
atid how will you know when you're done
that's a philosophical issue of like how
do we know we're done with building a GI
certainly for me I'm waiting to see a
lot of key moments for example I think a
really big moment will be when an AI
system comes up with a new scientific
discovery that's of Nobel prize-winning
level
that to me would be a big watershed
moment and I think an important step in
the capabilities of these systems so you
know capable some kind of true
creativity in some sense I think other
big points will be when it can use
language and converse with us in a
naturalistic way it's capable of
learning abstract concepts these are all
things that I think a high-level
cognitive abilities that we're nowhere
near yet and I think it'll be big so I'm
posts on the way when were you convinced
that all of this was possible well I've
had this in mind since my early teens I
probably read way too much so far I'm
guessing some were really formative
things on me were Asimov's foundation
series so interestingly not the robotics
books I haven't really read any of his
robot books but the foundation series
was this really amazing series of sci-fi
novels and then Ian banks has culture
series which is the sort of space opera
about how the universe would look after
humanity's bill AI and coexist with it
and then a really big scientific book
for me was when I was writing theme park
obviously I was working on AI and
building AI for the game but I was also
reading books like girdle or bark by
Hofstadter which I suppose is more of a
philosophy book but it's an incredible
piece of work tying together girdle's
incompleteness theorem about mathematics
with Asher's drawings and bass fugues
and showing that they're all related in
some way this repeating cycle of pattern
is infinite patterns that they they all
exhibit and then he tied it to
consciousness and intelligence and it
was just really inspiring for me and
made me think about these deep questions
and I was discussing this with a lot of
my friends who were you know we're
writing games together we were doing
that 24/7 and we would discuss these
things about what the limits of AI could
be if we could not just use it for what
we were doing in games but actually
advance it to the level where it become
the same level as human and I just felt
like the sky was the limit
I mean maybe another way I can put it is
if you look around us today you know you
look at modern civilization it's
incredible well what built modern
civilization
intelligence did right that's what
building human intelligence and if you
were to take us back to our
hunter-gatherer days 1020 thousand years
ago 30,000 years ago and you were to say
one day we're gonna build Manhattan and
then fly over from London to Manhattan
and on a 747 regularly above the clouds
I mean what would you have said that it
would be mind-boggling right
and yet humanity's done that incredibly
and I don't think we stopped to think
how amazing that is enough because the
other thing about the human brain is is
incredibly adaptable right as soon as
something you know we do something and
then it becomes kind of boring a Monday
and then it's trivial right but I always
think about that one I'm taking a
transatlantic flight about how have we
with our monkey brains managed to come
up with these types of technologies it's
unbelievable
100 ton of metal flying through the sky
above the clouds so reliably and so if
you think about that then if we now
build something like AG iron in and
enhance our own capabilities with this
amazing tool then I feel like almost
anything might be possible within the
laws of physics and perhaps even beyond
the laws of physics because with AI we
might discover more about the laws of
physics or some holes or flaws in our
understanding of the laws of physics so
if you think about that and you
extrapolate it a few hundred more years
with these kinds of technologies like
AGI around and then what we might be
able to build with AGI I think it could
be truly incredible where we'll be and I
feel it will be something like with the
realization of the true potential of
humanity
but however exciting the grand ambition
of AGI is there is also a need to
proceed with caution we're cognizant of
some of the technical questions around
AGI making sure that they do exactly
what we want how do we program in our
values how do we specify our goals so
these are all the theoretical and
technical questions around AGI that
people like Nick Bostrom are worried
about and so we and the Schoen leads our
safety team that works on a lot of these
questions from a research and technical
perspective and I think there's a lot
more work that needs to be done there
and I think that's what we're going to
see over the next decade or two but I
mean even if you proceed with caution
even if you act as safely as you
possibly can based on the information
that you have in front of you at that
moment you can't really mitigate against
bad actors you can't stop someone else
coming in and mucking up for everyone or
can you I think there are ways of
minimizing that I think we'll have to
think carefully about that like at the
moment we are at the stage where these
systems are still quite nascent they can
do impressive things like play go but
they are not yet properly
general-purpose or you know you couldn't
use them for anything very dangerous or
in the real world so we've committed
that we won't do certain applications
you know obviously like things like
military and surveillance so which we
think would be bad for society we don't
think AI should be applied to those
things and we certainly wouldn't do
ourselves but if you publish some great
algorithms you have to think about the
indirect impact of that if other people
bad actors and so on around the world
potentially use your algorithms for
things that you would not have agreed
with we have to use this time now to
think about what principles need to be
put in place whether that is carefully
thought-out regulation whether that is
technical solutions to these problems
mathematical proofs more engineering
solutions so like one of the projects we
have here we call it the virtual brain
analytics project and it's inspired by
what we do in neuroscience with fMRI
machines - brain scan people
while they're doing tasks and see what
parts of the brain light up so we can
understand what the brain is doing
better and we should be doing the
equivalent of that with our virtual
brains our artificial neural networks so
I think there's both sort of behavioral
there's experimental understanding and
them as mathematical understanding of
these systems and we should do all of
those and what I'm hoping is that we'll
eventually in the next few years have a
much better understanding of these
systems than we have today and we may
even have some mathematical proofs about
what if you want to limit a system in a
certain way what you need to do what
components do you require also you know
we have to think about publications and
other stuff that we talked about earlier
whether this free exchange of of
information and knowledge is okay even
under situations where there are
potentially dangerous applications and
where I would take our lead from this is
not the first time again this has
happened you know this has happened a
lot in biology with designing synthetic
biology and viruses embryology now with
CRISPR so boa G actually has a
long-standing multi-decade experience of
coming together with wider society and
the scientists and and regulatory bodies
and figuring out what are the rules of
the road that it's safe for everybody
and I think that's the kind of
coordination we're going to have to have
over the next decade where do you see
deep minder city in terms of the broader
tech industry in terms of ethics and
safety are people following your lead
we're only one company but we are the
biggest probably group anywhere in the
world and we you know are definitely one
of the world leaders and acknowledged as
so so that gives us a powerful platform
to set an example we can create ishutin
upon AI which is a cross industry
initiative to talk about some of these
issues in products and we've also
sponsored a lot of academic groups we've
given the money for postdocs and the
things arms-length to study this we have
close contacts with a lot of the
Institute's that work on these things
like the future of humanity institutes
just down the road Oxford we talk with
them all the time and we ourselves as
leaders at deep mind we've always talked
about ethics and I've always had that at
mine and the reason we have from the
beginning of deep mind is that we plan
for success so if we're
earning all these ambitious things for
AI to do then we also need to think
carefully about what would that mean and
so we're doing a lot of things behind
the scenes and I think by sort of being
an example that will influence everybody
else I'm hoping given that we're in the
lead technologically so for the moment
that's why I think also it's very
important we have a technical lead
because why would anyone listen to what
you have to say on the ethics one if
you're not one of the leaders
technologically right then you could
just be you know any group saying that
so I think to have a seat at the table
whether that's a country or a company or
even individual you need for credibility
purposes you have to be close to the
forefront of the technical technical
side itself where does the public fit
into all of this do you need to have the
trust in you as a technology company or
do they need to be on board at all can
you kind of do it without no it's really
critical that this is discussed at large
with society in everybody and the
general public and I think they need to
engage I mean the poem is is that a lot
of these technical things are very
complex and you need PhD to understand
them and so on but some of the
fundamentals are quite easy to
understand and what you really need to
understand is the consequences of it and
then society has to decide as I said
before about how these things get used
and how the benefits accrue to different
people and society and make sure that
that is fair and I think that's the key
thing is to engage with the public now
and try and educate them about some of
the complexities of the technology but
also the implications misses partly what
things like this podcast series is about
but also we've done a lot of public
engagement with the Royal Society the UN
day.i
series that we did last year and I think
a lot more of that has to be done are
you optimistic about the future yeah I'm
very optimistic about the future but the
reason I'm optimistic is because I think
AI is coming down the road and I feel
like if we build it in the right way and
we deploy it in the right way for the
benefit of everyone I think it's going
to be the most amazing transformative
technology that humanities ever invented
and I would be quite pessimistic about
some of the problems that we are facing
as a society like climate change and
sustainability or inequality I think
these are going to get exacerbated in
the next few
years and I'd be pessimistic about our
ability to solve that if there wasn't
something like AI on the way in the near
future I think in order to solve some of
these big problems challenges society
has we either need an exponential
improvement in human behavior more
cooperation less selfishness more
collaboration or we need an exponential
improvement in technology and
unfortunately the way politics is going
right now I don't really see much
evidence of the former and you know we
don't seem to be able to get our act
together
globally to do something about climate
anywhere near fast enough to deal with
the problem and so I think we have to
double down on a technical solution at
least we should try both but I think we
need some technology bets it's hard not
to be inspired by Demeter's insatiable
thirst for knowledge and find yourself
drawn in by his positive view of the
future because if I'm honest I'm
normally quite skeptical but I have a
lot of time for overly optimistic
marketing talk and one of my favorite
hobbies is to roll my eyes at
self-titled futurists at tech
conferences but you know over the last
12 months I've spent hanging around here
I've come to the conclusion that there
really is something quite special going
on at the cutting edge of AI after 50
years of quite slow progress it really
feels as though the field is finally
beginning to deliver the problems that
everyone thought were completely out of
reach only a few short years ago are
tumbling one by one and the science is
moving forward at a blistering pace both
here and at research labs all around the
world and the questions that people are
working on are profound and important
including some of the potential pitfalls
and ethical concerns of this kind of
technology so with all of that in mind I
think I'm going to join in demouth in
being optimistic about the future and
the potential of AI to be a real
positive force for good but don't just
take my word for it as we've said
throughout this podcast we hope to in
are you on your own a I'd Ernie maybe
even by finding the answers to some of
the biggest questions there are
I'm not intrapreneur a second I'm a
scientist first it's just that this was
the right vehicle to make this happen
and it seems to have worn out but if I
could have made it happen in academia or
just done it in academia it just wasn't
possible under the constraints academia
has and that's why we also sold the
company to Google because it was about
what accelerates the mission and the
science and ultimately that's what I
want to do if my life is I want to
understand what's going on here in the
universe both inside here in the brain
and externally out there in the universe
and I guess that's what's always driven
me is this deep desire to understand
what seems to me be incredibly
interesting and fascinating mysteries
that are going all around us and I don't
really understand why more people don't
think about that all the time I can
barely sleep because I'm just fascinated
and also troubled by the things around
us that we seemingly don't understand
all the big questions you know the
meaning of life have the universe star
what is consciousness all these
questions which I feel like a blaring
klaxon in my mind that I would like to
understand and my attempt at doing that
is to build AI first
if you would like to find out more about
some of the things that we've talked
about in this episode or explore the
world of AI research beyond deep mind
you'll find plenty of useful links in
the show notes for each episode and if
there are stories or a sources that you
think other listeners would find helpful
then let us know you can message us on
Twitter or email the team at podcast
that deepmind comm you can also use that
address to send us your questions or
feedback on the series deep mind the
podcast has been a whistle down
production binaural sound recordings
were by Lucinda Mason Brown the music
from the series has been specially
composed by Elena Shaw
producers were Amy racks and Dan Hardin
the senior producer was Louisa Field and
the series editor
was David pressed I'm Hanna Frey thank
you for listening